[Music]
[Applause]
it's bringing Peter King football
morning in America
nbcsports.com and back from Germany
where it seems like you had a great
vacation over there Pete uh how would
you sum it up for the audience
well the beer is good there this just
stands
um that's it Dan I thought it was it was
really a tremendous event overall I
talked to Pete Carroll before the game
and he said you know it feels like it's
going to be a like a college football
bowl game
and it turned out to be so much more
than that I think to me there's more
fervor there more excitement more
electricity than a conference
Championship Game and and and you know
to me there was so much about it
that fans there were so hungry about but
Dan two minutes left in the fourth
quarter
for some reason the stadium announcer
starts to place uh Take Me Home Country
Roads by John Denver and I'm saying okay
you've been playing music the whole game
I do not get this speaking of
non-sequiturs this is like the
non-sequitur of the year and all of a
sudden
we there is no Press Box per se uh at
allianzarine and Munich and at European
venues you're out in the stands
basically sitting at a in a chair with a
table okay but you're right there the
people in front of you are all bummed
but but so what happened
they started playing this I said this is
crazy who knows this song and every
single person among 69 000 I'm telling
you they all started singing Take Me
Home Country Roads so I called one of my
German fans who I had met with during
the week and talked to and he said oh
yeah everybody knows Country Roads by
John Denver we know that we know Sweet
Caroline we know all these songs they're
like all party songs and so but but the
whole week was so interesting one other
very quick thing then
I'm taking a tour I got my air pods in
I'm taking a tour of Munich uh that that
I had for my airpods and I'm in odion's
plots a very famous Square in Munich and
they're talking about Adolf Hitler tried
to overthrow the government right here
on this spot in 1923 and as I hear that
there's two guys starting to do a
Seahawks chant in the square there's an
NFL shop there there's 32 helmets in
this square of NFL teams and I just said
man what a difference a century makes it
just says this whole thing was just
quite a culture deal over that week we
always wonder is there an end game here
when London first happened or Mexico
City
you know now there's a report that uh
Spain and France could be on the on the
on well Spain is real okay Spain uh let
me tell you Dan I think the next two
countries that the NFL the new countries
that they go to
are Brazil and Spain
uh because the Miami Dolphins okay the
Miami Dolphins really have a following
in Brazilian they have a following in
Spain the Chicago Bears have a big
following in Spain so I think those two
are next but I will say I wrote this in
my column this week I think both Kansas
City and New England will be playing
home games next year in Germany most
likely in Frankfurt because of
scheduling with the Bundesliga but Dan I
just you know any question that the NFL
has about placing games in a new country
you know like Germany those were erased
about 10 minutes into this game these
people were crazy about it and not only
crazy about it but there were so many
people who were just euphoric they sent
us Tom Brady and so I think all of that
means next year when they send Patrick
Mahomes and Bill Belichick there it's
going to be a very big deal like again
to the citizens and football fans of
Germany all right what's the NFL's game
plan other than do one or two games in
these different cities there is there a
bigger picture here we should be aware
of Dan Roger Goodell has sort of put the
chum in the water that hey it's possible
to have a uh to have a division over
there like in Europe with four teams
how
I mean maybe 30 years from now but first
of all there's not a single owner that
wants a 36 team NFL not one
okay and there I can't think of a single
team right now that would even be
seriously thinking of relocation
I mean everybody always brings up
Jacksonville I I just I don't see shot
Khan moving this team but but let's just
say that he did one day eight years
seven years six years down the road
let's say he did who's gonna join him do
you know any owner in the NFL that wants
to move his team so unless you expand
where are you going to find the teams
the end game for now Dan to me is
instead of playing four or five games
outside the United States I think it
makes a lot of sense now next year at
the NFL meetings to push for eight to
ten games a year out of the NFL's 272
regular season games to be in different
countries is there a time frame for
Daniel Snyder to sell or do you get a
sense there's a time frame no I don't at
all I think he really wants to see
what's out there Dan that's what I've
heard
um and I agree I forget who wrote this
the other day but that he's not positive
what he's going to do there's a lot of
people who automatically assume that
he's selling the whole team especially
if he gets 8 billion or some insane some
and maybe he will but I don't think he's
made that decision yeah it feels we're
talking to Peter King from uh football
morning in America yeah it just feels I
don't know if what's happening with
Washington DC is speeding up things for
him that it's almost like I better get
out before the walls start closing in do
you sense that that is the fire starter
I think Dan I think we all think that
not only with all the legal stuff that
is playing out right now
but I also think you know wouldn't you
think that the political leaders of
Virginia of Maryland of the District of
Columbia would love to have a new NFL
stadium built uh you know in their
region no question about it they would
love to but right now they just they
don't want to go into business with
Daniel Snyder they want to go into
business with somebody else
did you get a chance to talk to Tom
Brady in Germany I did yeah I saw Matt I
actually saw him on Friday for a few
minutes uh at the Bucks practice and
talked to him and then talk to him after
the game for NBC you know just about the
game and
you know I really sense especially
because all you ever see with Tom is the
you know straight on hey look we all
deal with adversity in life which is
what he says but Danny's pretty solid in
in saying that and in and in talking
like that so I think that's really what
he's trying to focus on just football
and in trying to be sort of the best dad
he can in a very tough time for his
family but look I think the last uh 62
minutes of football
have really energized Brady like he
walked off after the game and saw me and
he was so first of all he's ridiculously
excited about what just happened I mean
that game was incredible he said it's
one of the best experiences he's ever
had in football told me that he felt
like he was in a Red Sox game when
they're all singing Sweet Caroline in
the stands and I just think
this game one of the reasons he came
back is that he just loves everything
about this game and you have a day like
you had on on Sunday it was 69 000
people just screaming on every play you
know it just there's there's a reason
why he doesn't want to get out a sense
that he's coming back next year
I don't I don't know Dan I don't and I
don't think he knows either I think he's
got to see where his life is at that
time and clearly Tampa Bay would want
him back
um you know but will he want to go back
there I I assume he would but I I think
it's too early to know and I don't even
think he knows yet
your MVP candidate uh candidates uh how
many quarterbacks how many
non-quarterbacks do you have right it's
crazy I wrote my column that if I were
picking one Monday morning I'd pick
Jalen hurts uh with Patrick Mahomes
second I might flip him right now but I
also think that you have to include the
Giants are seven and two saquon Barkley
at least has to be in the Outer Borough
the outer ring of discussion for it and
after watching that Vikings game Sunday
I know Tyreek Hills had a great year I
really and I totally totally respect him
but man Justin Jefferson is a big
difference maker I if if I'm gonna put a
Miami player you know in the discussion
you know for MVP I think I'd put two of
them because two and not only is played
great but when he hasn't played they've
lost that's the meaning of value and I
understand people argue about this all
the time oh my God tyrique's having a
better year all that stuff I'm not sure
he is but if in every game that he that
tuatanga Aloha has started and finished
the Miami Dolphins have won
and all three of their losses have come
when he hasn't played or played a very
limited role that says a lot to me about
value so probably my top three right now
would be those quarterbacks and I'll
tell you Josh Allen is going to get back
in the race I just think right now after
10 weeks especially after the last two
weeks you can't call on the MVP more
likely
to play next season Aaron Rodgers or Tom
Brady
I'd say more likely would be Rogers
I think Rogers comes back uh to Green
Bay
um now it depends how this year finishes
obviously
but I may be wrong about this but I
think if I'm Aaron Rodgers I do not want
to go out like this
plus there's 50 million dollars that
he's got coming his way next season
yeah and you know Dan there's there's
also part of this and you never know and
I haven't looked to what it would mean
to actually trade him somewhere uh as to
what it would mean cap wise for for
Green Bay if maybe look what I've said
Dan is I think that Jordan love if the
Packers are out of it in December Jordan
love should play that has to be part of
the long-term decision plan of the Green
Bay Packers can Jordan Love play and I
don't know what they're thinking I'm
sure they're not going to talk about
that right now but I do think right now
that that I want to see Jordan Love play
two or three football games I want to
see where he is sort of at the end of
year three
Mark Davis said uh here's the vote of
confidence for Josh McDaniels at two and
seven Rome wasn't building today
what's your take on this situation there
and with the Raiders everything are
there than him saying that I think he's
doing a fantastic job was he was right
on on on board with or right on the spot
with I think it's silly to say that
anybody who takes a playoff team and is
two and seven the next year is doing a
quote fantastic job end quote but to me
I think it was the right time for Mark
Davis to put out all the fires of we're
gonna fire Josh McDaniels after a year
that's a silly thing to do first of all
it's especially silly given that you
tore up your organization to bring in
Josh McDaniels and firing after him one
year instead of keeping Rich bisaccia
that the majority of players I think
with the Raiders wanted I think it's
just it would be a huge mistake
how many opportunities do you think Sean
Payton's going to have
I think he will have probably three or
four this year
uh if he wants them and I think that's a
big issue so Sean Payton this year with
his uh with his wife you know they've
moved to LA for the season
and his daughter lives out there and
they're experiencing a life without
football for a year and a couple of
times I've talked uh to Peyton he loves
it he's really having a good time I
don't think he goes anywhere where
either a
he cannot either pick the quarterback or
love the quarterback who is there so
let's say if Carolina wants him and
they've got the third pick in the draft
that quarterback is going to have to be
I mean he's not gonna he's not gonna
overthrow Scott fitter the general
manager but it's got to be who Peyton
wants and I think the second thing it
has to be a place where he thinks he's
got a very legitimate chance to win at
some point in the next couple of years
one of those situations is going to
beckon him I just don't know if it'll be
this year and I think he likes his life
right now I don't think he feels any
urgency that I have to come out and
Coach this year Pete great stuff as
always thanks for joining us okay Dan
thank you that's Peter King football
morning in America columnist and
contributes to football night in America